wir sind wieder an einem geheimen Ort
mit Vitali Klitschko dem Bürgermeister
der Stadt Kiew Vitali schönen guten
Mittag du siehst ich bin mittlerweile
mit einer Schutzweste hier du hast
normalerweise auch eine an wie
gefährlich ist die Situation
mittlerweile in der Stadt wenn man
draußen unterwegs ist dann trägst du
einen Helm und eine Weste mittlerweile
jetzt im Moment zuerst in bei uns in
Stadtrat
Linie gibt keine russische Armee
die kommen kämpfen die gehen zurück wir
haben unsere Armee hat richtig starke
Charakter gezeigt und seine Fähigkeiten
ist richtig stark die ganze Bevölkerung
jetzt unterstützt unsere
Patriotismus jetzt in duheime jede
hast Putin jede ist sehr sehr
patriotisch für die Ukraine und so viel
Leute ständig mein Telefon ist richtig
schon heiß von Anrufe Leute fragen wir
wollen Waffen wir wollen unser Land
verteidigen unsere Stadt verteidigen
Leute ist sehr patriotisch was betrifft
Situationen Innenstadt sehr viele
Gruppen touristische Gruppen russische
terroristische Gruppen
sehr viele nicht sehr viele aber
teilweise schon hier in Stadt deswegen
man muss aufpassen deswegen schussweste
ist richtige Entscheidung wann gehst du
raus bitte die dennoch ist es so dass
Russland in den Außenringen der Stadt so
scheint es zumindest immer mehr die
Kontrolle gewinnt zumindest und Russland
hat gesagt dass die Zivilisten die Stadt
verlassen sollen dass die Käfer lassen
soll ich will dir mal aktuelle Bilder
zeigen die mein Kollege Peter hell
gerade am Hauptbahnhof hier gefilmt hat
hier siehst du diese Bilder von der
Flucht das ist der Hauptbahnhof Kiew du
siehst wie Menschenmassen hier in den
Bahnhof gehen und die versuchen in einen
der letzten Züge zu kommen die es
rausgibt aus Kiew weil Russland sagt
Zivilisten sollten die Stadt sofort
verlassen es ist tatsächlich ein Massen
Andrang dort am Bahnhof hier siehst du
diese Massen die hochströmen dort raus
wie ist die Situation
Kinder eine ältere Leute
deswegen sehe ich Situationen das
selbstständig Leute sagt so etwas noch
nie erlebt in sehr viel ständig das ist
alles sind sehr nervös und
deswegen
ich verstehe jede keine wirklich
keine
viele solche Bilder erleben schreckliche
Bilder was jetzt verbreiten in Internet
deswegen
alle sind
unsicher weil in Russland hat gesagt die
betreffend
zivilette Bevölkerung nicht aber
trotzdem haben wir paar schon Beispiele
in unserer Stadt wenn Raketen in eine
Hochhäuser getroffen und sehr viele
Leute verletzt
was bedeutet das dass Russland jetzt
sagt Zivilisten sollen die Stadt
verlassen wir haben bei vergangenen
Kriegen erlebt dass die russische Armee
das Wladimir Putin nicht davor
zurückschreckt auch große Raketensysteme
einzusetzen wir haben eine hakiv gesehen
dass dort die Innenstadt bombardiert
worden es gehst du davon aus dass das
jetzt der Anfang einer größeren
Offensive ist das Russland jetzt noch
schlimmere Waffen einsetzen wird wenn
sie sagen die Zivilisten sollen jetzt
sofort die Stadt verlassen
schwierig im Kopf vom russischen
Präsident zu gehen das ist
krank das man hat nicht geile
tastenschrank das ich weiß ich nicht
welche Begriff muss ich
geben zu beschreiben wie man zum solche
Ideen kommt Ukraine zu angreifen weil
wir waren niemals aggressiv gegen keiner
landwir sind deine friedliche Volk
friedliches Land und ich habe einen
Wunsch gehabt dass es immer in Frieden
zu leben und jetzt ein Krieg das ist das
ist Albtraum für alle
ich kann nicht genau für Antworten die
viel Fragen beantworten hoffe ich nicht
selbstverständlich die Putin hat eine
wahnsinnige Vernichtungswaffen in
verschiedene
ich hoffe er wird das alles benutzen was
bringt Schaden für eine schwedische
friedliche Land und für eine friedliche
Volk für Menschen aber wissen was
keine ich kann nicht sagen was was tun
als Bürgermeister bist ja zuständig
nicht nur für die zivile Verteidigung
sondern vor allem auch für die
humanitäre Lage wie es momentan die
humanitäre Lage in Kiew in den
Krankenhäusern wie ist es mit der
Versorgung mit Nahrungsmitteln auch mit
Medikamenten
Logistik ist zerbrochen
und ist kein Geheimnis jetzt im Moment
die Menschen hat die Lebensmittel
Medikamenten aber schon wir haben
verschiedene Signale das ist der Leute
alle Marktes zu du wolltest verpflichtet
zu kaufen ist schwierig und schwierig
und mach mal die Menschen fragen wo
können wir Lebensmittel zu bekommen also
gibt es schon eine Knappschaft das ist
das ist wir kommen und denke ich mal ab
die nächste Tage das ist wird schon eng
mit Lebensmittel und mit Medikamenten
die ganze Infrastruktur die ganze
Service für Alltag für jeden von
Anwohner ist schon nicht wie vor einer
Woche jetzt man muss selbst kümmern wo
er muss Wasser kriegen oder Lebensmittel
oder Medikamenten oder Service
ja will glaubst du das ist wieder eine
theoretische Frage weil du hast ja
völlig recht wir können nicht in den
Kopf von Wladimir Putin schauen aber die
russische Kriegsstrategie war auch in
der Vergangenheit schon öfter in einer
Richtung dass man versucht eine Stadt
einzukreisen und ähm einzuzirkeln und
dann dafür zu sorgen dass eben
Nahrungsmittel nicht mehr durchkommen
Medikamente nicht mehr durchkommen um
dann die Stadt dazu zu bewegen den
Präsidenten dich dazu aufzugeben ist
dass die Taktik
tatsächlich das ist von logischen Seite
das ist
er versteht nicht das ist die Frage er
sagt das Schlechte Regierung aber das
ist richtig okay aber jede Burgen ist
dagegen jede Ukraine ist unterstützt du
keine unterstützt Regierung und habe ich
seine Rede ich gehört
gesehen wurde von mir Putin das
er hat eine Realität verloren erzählt
über Nationalisten erzählt oder
wie Nazis
das
wir verstehen nicht worüber spricht er
aber sehr viele Leute in Russland
Glauben an im waldpropaganda
funktioniert ziemlich stark und denke
ich mal das war richtige Entscheidung
Rasha Tode können Sie vorstellen einfach
eine
hat einen Budget mehr als Hauptstadt von
Kiew mehr als zwei Milliarden Dollar nur
einfach Budget von Russia Today weil
eine Medien ist eine wichtige Waffe in
Hände die in russische Diktatur und sehr
viele Rosen glauben das ist hier
Nationalisten des Narzissten das ist
deswegen er mag gute Sachen und die
bekommen keine richtigen Informationen
und aber glaube ich mehr und mehr Leute
wird nachdenken und und um zu sehen die
ganze Welt dagegen ganze Welt du hast
auch natürlich alte Freunde aus Russland
von von der ganzen Welt natürlich wie
glaubst du wie sehr kann Putin unter
Druck geraten jetzt im eigenen Land wir
sehen dass die wirtschaftsaktion wirken
wir erleben dass die Deutschen
Sanktionen wirken es gibt keine Flieger
mehr Rubel ist im freien Fall die Werte
werden dort vernichtet glaubst du das
macht Druck auf ihn dass der Krieger
beendet wird auf jeden Fall wer muss
nicht du bist eine verrückte Idee kommen
er muss denken und er sein Volk und
wissen Sie was das war nur für zwei das
ist die jede Geschäfte mit Russland zu
machen können Sie vorstellen die ganze
Geld was bringt bekommt russische
Regierung von Europa die investieren
nicht den Wirtschaft investieren nicht
in der Volk die investieren im Militär
in seine Armee und danach so passiert
was erleben wir heute in dukane wieder
die viele Menschen in Deutschland kennen
dich du bist ein Idol für viele Menschen
geworden durch 2014 aber auch schon als
Boxweltmeister zusammen mit deinem
Bruder Vladimir und ihr seid jetzt beide
24/7 hier unterwegs was macht das mit
dir persönlich wie geht es Dir dabei das
zu erleben in deiner Stadt in deinem
Land
aber schon mit Vladimir darüber mein
Bruder ist dabei und immer dabei
für unsere Mutter unsere Mutter hatte
riesige Sorgen und ist Mama mach keine
Sorgen ich
kümmere um jüngere und junge sagte Ich
kümmere Dich
ältere und deswegen versuchen wir unsere
Mutter beruhigen aber trotzdem sie ist
sehr groß
gut Bruder zu haben habe ich mit dem
darüber diskutiert dass es eine Albtraum
wenn jemand erzählt mir noch vor paar
Wochen das etwas passiert in meine Stadt
leere Straßen das ist blocken stehen auf
der Straße man darf nicht fahren das ist
die Terroristen Gruppen laufen durch die
Stadt wie die die die die ruinierte
Infrastruktur besonders die
Bombardierung in
Berlin die Häuser
bis jetzt ist schwierig zu begreifen
denke ich mal wir brauchen noch ein
bisschen Zeit zu einfach zu verstehen
so etwas zu erleben
ich habe eine Gefühl ich habe keinen
Bruder ich habe mich mit ihm diskutiert
dass es eine wie wir sind im Kino eine
Fantasie oder horror movie aber das ist
Realität das ist gerade Realität und
unsere Wand und meine Aufgabe jetzt im
Moment schnell wie möglich an Menschen
zu helfen weil alle kennen mich in
meinen Staat und ich bin Leiter von der
Stadt und alle Fragen wegen Wasser wegen
Service wegen Krankenhäuser Krankenbette
und aber jetzt im Moment ist ziemlich
schwierig wir versuchen mit ganz so
unsere Team das ist alles orange schnell
ist wie möglich dass es Menschen zu
unterstützen und noch gleichzeitig
unsere Stadt zu verteidigen dennoch
fragen sich viele Menschen in
Deutschland auch die Fans sind von euch
beiden wie gefährlich ist das für euch
Wladimir Putin wird dich hassen weil du
für das stehst was den besten ausmacht
du hast dann mal dann gestanden
demonstriert du bist pro westlich du
hast in Deutschland Amerika gewohnt
haben hat Wladimir Putin ist auf dich
abgesehen
ich bin zu Hause
das ist meine Stadt ich fühle mich hier
wohl ich
so viel habe ich so viele Energie
investiert das ist meine Vision zu
implementieren das ist die Stadt Kiew
muss richtig mit europäischen Standard
eine sehr sehr schöne und historische
Stadt zu ändern zum gute Seite zu Ende
und deswegen
keine Kampf von mir wegnehmen mein Traum
zum ersten zweites
Ich bin in mein Land und drittes
an zu haben wovon
ich bin zu Hause davor ermordet zu
werden eventuell
jeder von uns irgendwann steht
alles
ehemalige sauplatte ich eine
habe ich gespürt
wenn mein Land braucht mein Leben dann
muss ich mein Land beteiligen und wenn
nötig wird mit Lebenszahl
Vitali ein Ausblick zum Schluss auf die
nächsten Tage die nächsten Nächte jetzt
sind gerade Friedensverhandlungen hast
du irgendeine Hoffnung dass etwas dabei
rauskommen kann und wie wird das
weitergehen wenn nichts dabei rauskommt
wie lange wird sich hier verteidigen
können wie lange wird es dauern bis
Russland tatsächlich die Stadt umzingelt
hat Paul danke für die Frage das ist
sehr wichtig wenn haben wir
Unterstützung von Deutschland danke für
alle während du keine aber gesehen dass
es tausende hunderttausende Millionen
von Menschen gestern eher auf der
Straßen gegangen und protestiert gegen
unmenschliche Aktivität russische
Aktivitäten was passiert und in unserem
Land ich danke für Ihre von ganzem
Herzen aber von eurer Meinung von eurer
Position abhängig die Zukunft von
unserem Land wir werden wir werden
kämpfen für unsere Zukunft für unser und
wenn
sie unterstützen uns politisch moralisch
dann kann der was kann deutsche tun die
das jetzt die uns zuschauen hier gerade
bei Bild live wo wir in einem geheimen
Ort in Kiew sitzen was kann an Zuschauer
tun soll er spenden soll er auf die
Straße gehen jetzt mal während ich bin
nicht auf der Straße zu gehen das ist
eine Meinung zu sagen an
russische Botschaft an alle Russen das
ist die Berufung müssen aufwachen und
verstehen dass es alles was passiert das
ist keine moderne Welt das ist die
Methoden von Mittelalter
ich möchte
bestimmt wir brauchen eine argumentäre
Unterstützung bestimmt wir brauchen
Lebensmittel bestimmt wir brauchen
Medikamenten aber
die Kontakt mit euch Politiker aber die
wichtigste das ist mit Herz und
Verstopfung moralisch Unterstützung
dabei mit uns zu sein das ist sehr
wichtig und dafür möchte ich bedanken
jetzt hat Deutschland diese harten
Sanktionen über die wir seitdem wir uns
kennen 2013/14 wird es mal ganz und dann
der Grimm und der aus Ukraine die du
immer gefordert hast jetzt wird das
umgesetzt und Olaf Scholz hat sich
plötzlich um 180 Grad gewendet der
Bundeskanzler und hat eine harte Rede
gegen Russland gehalten und diese
Sanktionen gegen Moskau gehalten und und
Putin gehalten und diese Aktion
umgesetzt wie nimmst du die deutsche
Politik war
ich freue mich sehr viele Leute
aufgewacht ja die hat nie geglaubt
ehrlich keinen kann glauben so etwas
kann passieren aber die jede aggressive
Aktivität muss eine Antwort bekommen
Handels geht nicht und deswegen danke
für jede deutsche Politiker weil endlich
mal verstanden was bedeutet russische
empirische Ambitionen
was ist
Vitali wir haben gestern erlebt dass
Wladimir Putin über Atomwaffen
gesprochen hat über Provokation des
Westens was ist wenn Vladimir Putin
nicht mehr zurechenbar ist also
unzurrechenbar ist
was passiert dann auf dieser Welt
aber die ganze Welt kann nicht auf
aufstehen
wir müssen sprechen wir müssen
überzeugen aber wissen Sie was sehr sehr
wichtig denke ich mal
wenn er hört nicht Westen glaube ich in
sehr kurzer Zeit
er fängt an zu hören Osten ich meine die
seine Burger wer wird verstehen wir sind
dort festen auf den Straßen mit mit
Sanktion das ist die jede Russen denkt
wieso bekommen wir keine westliche
Produkten die wir wieso wir haben keine
westliche Service wieso die moderne Welt
steht nicht mehr mit Gesicht zu uns das
ist Druck von Innenland von Russland in
Russland muss ein Druck aufwachsen gegen
Polen weil er muss seine
Idee stoppen es geht nicht das ist alle
gemeinsam müssen wir erklären oder
Zeugen und
sagen dass unmenschliche Aktivitäten
seit zweiter Weltkrieg in europäische
Raum so etwas noch nie passiert wie
sieht dein Tag heute aus deine Nacht
heute aus was machst du
[Applaus]
die letzte Tage habe ich ich schlafe
sehr wenig und
sehr anstrengend sehr viel Termine sehr
viele Kommunikation zwischen
Zivilisten Armee
die der territuale Verteidigung und zu
hilfebeteiligung noch Service an
Menschen zu geben sehr viele
telefonieren mit westliche Partner mit
sehr viel Politiker mit Menschen mit
burgewerb der
haben Hoffnung und die brauchen Hilfe
von mir
sehr sehr anstrengend wir haben das soll
hier Zeit habe ich noch nie gehabt so
stehen gezeigt hast du Zeit mit deinen
Kindern zu sprechen wie viel Sorgen
macht sich deine Familie nicht in der
Ukraine sind
ich habe
gestern habe ich nun wieder mit meiner
kleinen gesprochen mit kleinsten
nicht mehr klein
weil 17 Abonnenten wenig Zeit sogar
sogar mit mit Kindern zu sprechen und
alle haben Sorgen schicken mir SMS
auf sie ist
pass auf Dich auf ähm sagen die Kinder
von Vitali Klitschko in diesen Tagen und
damit
gebe ich zurück nach Berlin vielen Dank
vielen herzlichen Dank an Paul
ronsheimer und ein Vitali
Bürgermeister der Stadt gegangen sind
mit Euch beiden dankeschön